jours pour préparer l'après fessenheim
et 16 élus haut rhinois de tous bords
ont pris position dans une tribune pour
demander des engagements précis à l'état
pour amortir l'impact économique de
cette fermeture les explications de
stéphane caudry ils sont seize des élus
haut rhinois de la majorité
présidentielle et de l'opposition des
parlementaires et des élus locaux
16 signataires qui veulent rappeler à
l'état que derrière la décision
symbolique de fermer fessenheim
il y à un territoire et des réalités
économiques reconvertir un territoire
qui est aussi intimement liées à
l'activité industrielle que le
territoire de fessenheim
ça va prendre du temps ça va prendre de
l'énergie ça à prendre des moyens et
aujourd'hui il faut qu'on s'attelle à
ses moyens parce que c'est l'enjeu de
nos concitoyens l'avenir économique d'un
territoire qui est en jeu dans leur
tribune publiée ce matin les élus
annoncent avoir des propositions
concrètes en matière de développement
économique
ils veulent notamment placé le
département à la pointe de la recherche
sur la transition énergétique
nous allons faire des propositions dans
le cadre des énergies renouvelables
d'une part et d'autre part dans le cadre
d'un centre de recherche par rapport aux
énergies du futur et de l'industrie du
futur et de l'agriculture du futur des
pistes d'avenir auxquels doivent
s'ajouter une fiscalité avantageuse voir
des dérogations en matière de droit
économique et social pour lutter contre
la concurrence allemandes et les élus
comptent aussi sur le soutien financier
de l'état pour compenser la perte de
recettes fiscales estimé à 12 millions
par an pour les collectivités locales
faudra aussi la désengagement de l'état
pour garantir les revenus sur une seule
union une certaine période
maintenant parce que sinon les que ce
soit la com com la commune de les
communes de la région qui touche d
des retombées seront en difficulté alors
que la fermeture de la centrale se
profile pour la fin de l'année
le secrétaire d'état sébastien lecornu
devra apporter des réponses aux demandes
des élus haut rhinois le levothyrox